-Adam, you're getting
a standing ovation here,
even though you're on Zoom.
-Yep.
-That's --
Oh, you love --
-Come on. Give me as much
as you gave Anthony.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
Oh, you're the best, buddy.
I'm so happy to see you.
Thank you so much
for doing the show.
I appreciate it.
-Yeah, yeah.
Thanks, man.
Thanks for having me.
I also got the omicron, so...
-Did you really?
-That's why I'm here, or else
I'd be in studio with you.
-Wow. How are you feeling
with the omicron?
-I feel...stronger.
[ Laughter ]
It gave me the adverse effects.
-Wow!
-I don't know -- no.
I'm gonna get a call from Fauci.
I can't be spreading
that information.
It was the same thing.
I was sick for like three days.
-Yeah.
-But I'm back now, baby.
-Yeah, I'm happy your back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You look good.
-Yeah.
-And thank you for doing this.
I wanted to say congratulations
to you, because you
recently got married.
That's a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, this little thing?
-Whoa! Look at that.
Look at the ring.
♪♪
How did you and your wife meet?
-It's a real meet cute, Jimmy.
We actually met on a plane.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Wow.
-Ooh! Yeah.
We were shooting the same movie,
but I didn't know that
because I'm an idiot
who doesn't read e-mails.
I just -- like, they just
pushed me onto an airplane.
And I'm like,
"Where am I going?"
They're like,
"You're shooting a movie."
I'm like, "Okay."
But Chloe is a smart person
who reads e-mails,
and she knew who I was.
And so, she's, like,
trying to chat me up.
And, meanwhile, I just think,
"This babe is hitting on me."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like
a little overwhelmed.
I had a girlfriend at the time.
I'm like,
"I don't want any of this.
I don't know.
I get it.
I'm charming."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-And then, we land,
and I realize
we had the same driver
to take us from New Orleans
to Baton Rouge.
And I'm like,
"Oh, you're in the movie!"
She's like,
"Yeah. What did you think?"
I'm like, "No, no, I knew.
I knew you were."
[ Laughter ]
And we're driving,
and she goes, "Should we get
some drive-through daiquiris?"
Which is a thing
you can do in New Orleans.
There's a drive-through
daiquiri place.
I know -- it's great.
[ Cheers ]
And she's -- I'm like,
"Well, what size?"
I didn't want to, like,
get too big of a size and,
you know, be like,
"Oh, is this guy a drunk?"
So, but she ordered first,
and she's like,
"I'll take
the 48-ounce party starter."
And I was like --
-You're like,
"Will you marry me?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Will you marry me?"
-"Will you marry me?
Who are you?"
Unicorn.
-You know what?
The time is now.
-Congratulations.
I know that you're gonna do a --
you're doing
a "Pitch Perfect" series.
I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love the movie.
-Yeah.
-Based around your character.
What can you say about it?
I know you're not filming it
yet, but is it happening soon?
What can you say?
It --
Essentially, it takes place
around my character
after the second movie,
and Bumper goes on "The Voice,"
and you think his career
is gonna skyrocket.
But he releases an album, and it
totally tanks here in America.
And he runs into some German
tourists and they're like,
"Oh, my God,
you're huge in Germany.
Like, you have a song
that's a hit."
So then,
Bumper packs up his stuff
and goes to Germany to try
to make it as a pop sensation.
-That's fantastic.
-Which is...
-I will love that.
-...when you're nearing 40
is when --
is when your pop stardom
really starts to peak, I feel.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's talk about
"Righteous Gemstones."
Very funny. Season two premieres
this Sunday at 10:00 p.m.
on HBO and HBO Max.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, it's so funny.
Everyone's so good in this.
But you get to really go off
and play --
Kelvin is your character.
-That's right.
-Some of your outfits,
I just chose some of them
just to show what
your character dresses like.
This is from that past season.
[ Laughter ]
It's fashionable.
-Yeah, he's pretty chill.
-Yeah, I would say chill, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-I feel like
I realize that I just recently
learned the word "cheugy."
Do you know
what the word "cheugy" means?
-Yes, cheugy.
-Yeah.
I'm cheugy.
-Yes! Oh, my gosh!
Kelvin is cheugy.
-All of Kelvin's outfits
are cheugy, which is like
you're trying too hard
or you're like -- you have
something that maybe
was cool in the past
and no longer isn't cool at all.
That's what I am, both as
a person and as an actor.
-No, no, no,
your character is cheugy.
Well, we love you, buddy.
You're always so fun.
Thank you so much.
And hopefully next time
in person, okay?
-Absolutely.
Good to see you, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Best to your wife.
-Thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Adam Devine
in "The Righteous Gemstones."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Let's not fill up
on rolls here.
Stick to the salad bar.
Don't forget --
we are swimming laps
after lunch, so eat light.
We nourish our bodies
for his love.
Coo'.
-So cool.
-Excuse me, sir.
-What's up?
Dismissed.
-It's just...
Will you be dining
with the men and I?
-[ Scoffs ]
Of course not, Keefe.
I'll be above you,
upstairs, with the family.
-Shall I join you?
-Oh, not appropriate.
Upstairs church lunch
is only for the family.
-See you upstairs, Kelvin.
-And daddy's
closest work acquaintances.
-There you go.
Adam Devine, everybody.
Season two
of "The Righteous Gemstones"
premieres this Sunday at
10:00 p.m. on HBO and HBO Max.